a skeleton service on a network beset by
strikes
just 20 of trains were running on a
fourth day of national industrial action
that removed the rush from rush hour and
left commuters taking a chance that
their train would be running were you
surprised to find trains working or did
you think i'd take a risk um we've come
for an appointment so we have calm so i
was aware but i did think it wouldn't be
that busy because a lot of people won't
be commuting today well they haven't
totally shut all the trains down so i
suppose
they're trying to make a point that's
the way to do it what do you think about
the strike they're making a point about
for working people to get a decent play
rise do you think i can't argue with
that yes power to the people
[Applause]
the rmt has rejected a payoff are worth
up to four percent a year and a
guarantee of no compulsory redundancies
but without a vote a deal network rail
thinks its members would accept we think
the right thing to do now is to put that
to a vote of my staff
and that's the way that this will get
called off because when people see that
deal
i believe that they will recognize it's
a good deal and it's also a fair deal
because it doesn't ask taxpayers to pay
more and it doesn't ask for fair payers
passengers to pay more either
this has become a profoundly political
dispute with unions blaming the
transport secretary for tying the
employer's hands and government
threatening to curb the right to strike
the idea that we're running some
ideological campaign is nonsense frankly
what we want to do is get a settlement
so straightforward industrial dispute on
jobs pay and conditions and we can be we
could do that if grant chaps would allow
the companies to negotiate freely we
need to i'm afraid do more
to remove the power of these very
militant extreme left unions from
disrupting everyday lives to ordinary
people
network rail had hoped it could avert
this strike they felt talks last week
were heading in the right direction but
after the rmt rejected its payoff of the
union has again demonstrated that it
could bring the railways practically
to a halt but thanks to working from
home the travelling public and perhaps
the economy are more resilient than once
they were this could be a protracted
dispute
in birmingham where the commonwealth
games begin on thursday a national
strike and a local headache though
organisers are confident events will
remain on track the rail strike today at
least one day before the games people
have been able to plan around it and we
do have a strike from aslef in the west
midlands on saturday but we are
absolutely determined to run a
contingency plan so nobody will prevent
people coming here and using public
transport to get to the games talks are
due to resume later this week with train
drivers already voting for more strikes
in august unless the spirit of harmony
here rubs off disruption may last deep
into summer pool so sky news in
birmingham